scratch the surface of security and you
get a prompt abridgement of Liberty
Benjamin Franklin said to his countrymen
those who would give up liberty for
security will lose both and deserve
neither today there are politicians in
every country who fanned the fears of
the public who play on the economic
difficulties who promote hatred and
xenophobia and the uni dimensional view
of society and used ensuing distress to
build a power base and to dictate the
state the course that it should follow
yet human experience and social context
are never in dimension and neither are
we I mean Maloof has rightly warned us
about those who would seek to label us
in uni dimensional identities and he
call these rightly murderous identities
the humanists the idealists and those
politicians committed to public service
rather than power seem unable on your
side or ours to stem the tide of hate
mongers exclusionist sand the servants
of melon despite having infinitely more
communication and interaction today than
in past generations we have a world
where the mounting evidence of science
remains ignored where the warnings of
the thoughtful remain unheeded where the
cries of dispossessed remain unanswered
a world where the commitment to vision
and action has been replaced by a
dedication to process without progress
we have lost the quality of our public
discourse the toxic poison of that
politics of hatred and fear is such that
readings of great works destroyed the
universally the universality of the
creative genius that made them great in
the first place and is slide into
various forms of chauvinism the snitch
it becomes Nazi propaganda Kipling
becomes jingoism on my side of the
Mediterranean the extremists interpret
the legacy of Islam as exclusionary and
intolerant what a shell how can thinking
people on both sides of the
Mediterranean allow such drivel to
dominate the airwaves and the arena of
public discourse I'm not calling for
censorship far from it I'm calling for
action to redeem the values that we hold
essential in our historical legacies and
current societies we need to fight ideas
with ideas we need to speak up we need
to repeat the feats of the post-war
generation of visionary Europeans we
need to articulate a vision for the
future that is worthy of the best
traditions of our heritage we need to
remind the public that there is no
security without peace there is no peace
without justice there is no justice
without equity and there is no equity
without participation and that is the
meaning of true pluralism Pru
cosmopolitanism and that brings me back
to my fourth point which is about
Alexandria the spirit of Alexandria as a
guide to the world today let us heart
back to that spirit of the Alexandria of
old which revealed knowledge and sought
it from all the cultures of the world to
the spirit of modern Alexandria which
linked Europe and Egypt and yield there
we can find the thread of area that will
help us out of the labyrinth of false
issues and phony problems and to get us
out of the morass we are in we need to
revive that spirit in the context of our
times I am not only an unabashed
humanist so Bremen introduced River also
an unabashed proponent of
cosmopolitanism I mean after all the
word derives from the Greek cosmos the
universe and polished the city the
universal city after all the greatest
cities in the world were always
quadrants of cosmopolitanism by that I
mean cosmopolitanism such as was found
in ancient Alexandria
ancient Rome or throughout the cities of
the Muslim empires of the Middle Ages or
more recently in the great cities of the
West such as London New York Paris and
Amsterdam all embraced many diverse
communities cultures and languages while
still having their own distinct
character and contribution dominated by
the dominant language of the era and the
expression of the locality in space and
time cosmopolitan is a philosophical
tradition that encompasses many
distinguished proponents from German
philosophers such as Kant and Hegel for
african-american contemporary
philosophers such as Kwame appeal
because napolitan ISM allows us to enjoy
the richness of our diversity confident
in the strength of our common humanity
look at India today thousands of
communities dozens if not hundreds of
languages and subcultures but still
unified under the Indian identity and in
Alexandria of times past that same
spirit of cosmopolitanism flourished we
need that spirit three by Apollo 21st
century and we need to marry it with the
best of the European tradition but to do
that we need to develop new thinking for
this new age can we do that